yolande c'est squeeze aujourd'hui on se
trouve non pas sur un jeu j'ai envie de
faire autre chose que des eaux sur un
jeu aujourd'hui mais je savais pas trop
quoi faire
donc j'ai demandé sur twitter de me dire
quoi faire de donner des ordres que je
me réserve le droit bien sûr de ne pas
exécuter un donc finalement c'est plus
des ordres c'est parti on commence mes
sept matchs mano dans ta bouche et
chante et macarena c'est chiant ça et
c'est encore plus chez encore mais que
sa cote est au cinéma cette ça va être
compliqué on va le tenter à léon le
temps tu as mais cette ce rambo site les
jeunes m 7
[Musique]
ok
plus jamais ça les un jeune un truc
oblats ni vu ni connu refait la
chorégraphie de i'm single avec la tenue
qui va avec bien sûr clin d'oeil je
refuse totalement de faire cette
chorégraphie et encore plus avec cette
tenue totalement
[Musique]
faire un tour de magie trop stylé ya qu
un seul tour de magie que je sais faire
[Applaudissements]
dalbandin tout ce que j'avais la tête du
mec concentré de merde juste avant de
faire ça voilà donc pratiquer ce tour
assez régulièrement par exemple à ça
faisait un an que j'avais pas fait et
c'est toujours bien pour épater la
galerie
pour épater son chat entre autres est du
coup j'ai envie de le refaire encore et
encore au revoir maintenant j'ai raté
danse le caramel dance and je sais pas
du tout comment ça se disait-on saljic
armelle dansant et oui ça me fait un
truc attendait
ça fait mal au cul à prothèse à la
hanche dans deux jours allez je suis sûr
j'ai déjà vu ce truc là et pas qu'une
fois en plus à ce qui explique
d'ailleurs pourquoi je danse si bien
raconter imite le rhinocéros tout ce que
je sais du rhinocéros et qui charge qui
fait peur donc je vais charger faire
peur ok on imite plus jamais les animaux
est vrai que je mette la caméra fait de
la chirurgie esthétique avec du scotch
merci aux fédéraux berne le conseil
jamais jamais pensé ça coûte extrêmement
moins cher que la vraie syrie rogier et
les résultats sont tout aussi
convaincant déjà ça faut le tirer vers
l'arrière pour effacer les rides ya des
rides là au dessus il faut abaisser sa
scandaleuse
howie aux éléves autant d'heures et
voilà une chirurgie au scotch au direct
8 où moi c'est horrible de faire
s'élever en fait lucas quelqu'un d'autre
lucas du cas toujours crocs dans un
citron bien juteux on va faire ça
ensemble j'ai ici une manivelle ainsi qu
un accordéon ceux ci totalement faux je
vais couper de sorte à ce que je puisse
bien croquer dedans après ben on va
tenter un rebond violent l'a tout de
suite dans les médias là franchement
après on s'est habitué ses bons vins
j'aime bien dessiner une personne au
choix grâce à une photo et montre-nous
l'original et ton dessin vous fait ça
elle en pense qu'il nous faut un couteau
et un citron annonce est bon je
connaissais bien mon talent pour le
dessin est bonne non non non franchement
est franchement il ya un truc
ne me dites pas le contraire déjà il ya
un truc au niveau de la barbe ok il ya
un petit problème au niveau de l'index
qui fait 30 cm et voilà bref allez
cordialement on a zappé les rides du
front c'est tout ce qui m'importe
mais quand est-ce que je ne saurais
dessinée peux tu faire un ied jauge pas
commencé à se diriger est mignon comme
les coréens ah oui c'est les positions
mignonne que font les coréens alors à
temps
non mais ça va pas marcher ça m'a pas du
tout fou léger [ __ ] [ __ ] par contre
ça va bien chez des poils center total
fame est est mignon nettoie ton change
pas de le nettoyer ce n'est toi tout
seul avec sa petite l'homme rappeuse
comme ça fait même preuve de souplesse
en faisant ça et même parfois ça voire
même ceux ci voudraient scheer légende
d'un autre homme non extrême comme vous
et je trempe et un mec d'ange pas dans
du fromage gras toi tes oreilles avec
tes pieds comme les chats et ben ça
tombe bien puisque m'étais déjà lente et
un bol fine line coutu tombe bien sont
tranquillement posé lorsque d'un coup
roccat tu dois te dessiner une fleur sur
le frontal droit à google images bout du
lac
bon on va quand même se passer de google
images pour dessiner une simple fleur
c'est parti et que ça part mal un pétale
de pétales médiature trois pétales
c'est à ça que ça vous faisiez
pensez-vous aussi j'ai tout donné vers
cette fleur au plus tard alors pourquoi
on dirait le cesit kirikou et voilà les
joueurs se dire enfin de cette petite
vidéo où j'espère que ça vous a plu si
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à l'aimer ou
à vous faire une chirurgie au score
c'est comme vous voulez hop là c'est un
patch pour un noah et les points noirs
sur le scotch bombarde de faire sa fille
je sais que je vais me répéter en disant
ça mais j'adore faire ce genre vidéo
vous interagissez avec moi je sais pas
vous fait marrer
n'hésitez pas à me dire dans les
commentaires si vous voulez d'autres
vidéos de ce genre voire même à vos
ordres 2 pourquoi pas en tout cas on se
retrouve très vite dans une prochaine
vidéo
merci d'avoir regardé à tout le monde
bis
[Musique]